how you doing steve
i really can't complain congrats on the
movie
thank you thank you very much i i think
it's going to be what we call a huge hit
oh wow thank you
that's that's a good thing
i'm sure that will make the the upper
echelon of netflix very happy
uh yes i'm confident so uh speaking of
netflix i am curious what was your
reaction when you heard that green
lantern was in the top 10 out of nowhere
um i don't know what my reaction was i
was a little surprised to be honest um
that people are revisiting i also think
that the the dc universe is is you know
is pretty fascinating these days so i
think people are probably keeping i
think they're rebooting it as well so
maybe they're keeping an eye on it for
that i don't know exactly i have no
privy to that i'm not privy to any of
the metrics or data as to why but uh
power to him great
um you've done you've made a lot of
movies uh if someone has never seen
anything that you've made what do you
want them to start with
they've never seen anything i've ever
made
i would love them to start you know i'm
partial to the movies i've produced
so the movies i've genuinely kind of
produced from the ground up deadpool
deadpool 2
free guy the upcoming adam project
certainly adam project is i would say is
probably one of my most
personal movies i've ever done
um not to give too much away but that
one is really special to me so uh those
i would say those four free guy is a i
think a great antidote to the kind of
dark dark-ish times we live in right now
so
completely agree um
you own a liquor company and dwayne also
has a liquor company and i'm just
curious you guys both got to do a little
product placement in the movie did you
find that dwayne was carrying a bottle
of taramana so that when every shot he
was like right before the cameras rolled
you just stick the bottle down like in
the background trying to one-up
he probably should what's funny about
the product listening is i've done it on
a couple of films and then everyone does
it for me now like i i you know it was
it was a surprise to me that the effects
guys put a way deep in the background in
free guy there's a little icon that says
gratuitous product placement and it's
just sort of floating there in the
background as an icon but like so
sometimes it happens when i don't even
know it's going to happen but the the
one in red note is i i'm you can't make
this up you know who suggested dj
dj is the one who said let's bring in
some aviation and put it on the table
here in this you know sure great it's
your show he's producing the movie so
it's like
your world i'm just living in it i'd
love to have it in the movie so we put
it in the movie there and
and then i think taramana shows up in a
couple other spots so
yeah
uh one of the things uh i think that i
don't think a lot of people realize who
are maybe newbies to movies really what
it takes to do these action set pieces
and how much time really goes on behind
the scenes so using the example of the
in the third act the mind uh chase and
the vault can you sort of maybe take me
through what it really takes to make an
action set piece like that
yeah i mean that particular set piece
was divvied up because we shut down for
the pandemic for seven months so we shut
down right in the middle of that
um
and
you know that's a challenge because
there's so many different logistics from
a safety standpoint and just a sort of
spectacle standpoint that you have to
kind of put on hold abandon and then
revisit so many months later so that was
weird and unusual but um you know
half of it was shot in a salt mine that
was something like four or
500 feet underground i mean it was this
wild kind of place in georgia that um
had this incredible salt mine so yeah it
was it was logistically incredible but
for us it's more about character you
want to infuse as much character as
possible in action sequences otherwise
they're sort of mind-numbing so you you
know you want it to have humor and charm
and sort of weirdness
involved which we were able to do but
there's one line that we i don't think
it's in the movie but
where it's it's the moment we shot one
moment and then we shut down for seven
months for the pandemic but we resumed
right into the next moment and i and
there's a scene where i'm looking at
dwayne and he's looking at me and i he
finally says what what are you looking
at and i said nothing you look seven
months older uh and it was it was the
second it was literally the moment we
picked up shooting seven months later
and
it doesn't stay in the movie but it's in
the middle of that whole underground
bunker action sequence
that's a funny line uh i already got to
stop i'm just going to say man congrats
on the movie like i said it's going to
be a huge hit uh thank you for giving me
your time
always a pleasure thanks steve take care
you